it became official on monday
dak prescott signing the franchise
tender the exclusive tender the 31.4
million you know they didn't have to do
31-4 they could have done the
non-exclusive in the range of 26 or 27
and then they would have run the risk of
someone swooping in and making him an
offer the cowboys couldn't or wouldn't
match and the cowboys get two
first-round picks in return somebody
asked me yesterday
have they really decided he's the guy
the fact that they used the exclusive
franchise tender the highest level of
31.4 million for this year tells me
they've decided he's the guy chris
because they had other options
less than that that would have saved
them money and given them flexibility if
they hadn't gone all the way to the
top-end option yeah i i mean he is the
guy and and it does seem like there's a
a faction of the dallas cowboy fan base
that can't accept that yet or or wants
something better that's out there and
you know what i would say to them always
you know the green is not always grass
or on the other side i mean
the ground it crashes always greater
we're gonna have a new volume in place
by the end of the week that
is that's beautiful although although
based on some of your habits
probably technically correct that the
green isn't grassier on the other side
not always
there's lots of grass out here and
there's
but but in all seriousness i mean this
is a guy yes they do know he's the guy
they want to move forward you're right
they've given us all the signals to say
we believe in this guy we think he's the
franchise and we're moving forward with
dak prescott you know hey yeah is he
gonna be a top five quarterback in his
football career at some point i think so
i mean as you think as you know right
now i got him as the number eight
quarterback in my chris sims top 40
countdown i think he's on the cusp of
that but i don't know you know is there
a lack of pizzazz or like you know just
showmanship that dak prescott doesn't
have that won't get some of the fan base
in dallas and people to buy into him i
do think it's kind of weird mike um and
again i'm not trying to say he's patrick
mahomes or aaron rodgers or or russell
wilson but uh i still think he's got a
lot of qualities to be that guy and be
the starting quarterback for the dallas
cowboys for a long time and and lead
that offense to big numbers and big
points and a lot of wins
now the challenge is to get a long-term
deal done by july 15 after that
they're stuck with this one-year deal
that's already been signed he's under
contract they can't do another deal
until after the end of the regular
season
and remember it's this simple he's got
31.4 now officially in hand
37.68 is what he would make next year
under the franchise tag by rule he gets
a 20 increase doesn't matter what
happens with the salary cap doesn't
matter what happens with the quarterback
market cap goes up cap goes down market
goes up mark goes down doesn't matter
he's locked in for 37.68 million under
either tag next year transition or
franchise so
what are they going to offer him to get
him to say
i will surrender 31.4 now
37.68 next year and a potential kirk
cousins path to free agency in 2022
unless they want to pay him 54.25
million under the franchise tag for a
third time because he'd be in line for a
44 raise and it's like anything else
that you're selling chris right you got
a car that you're selling your options
are keep the car or sell the car what
are they going to offer you to buy your
car and is it enough for you to do it
well dak's car is a
69.08 million dollar chevy plus the
opportunity to potentially become a free
agent
what does it take on a long-term deal
for him to say
i'll take the long-term deal instead of
what i already have that's the question
that will happen over the next three
weeks yeah i mean we know some of that
already they want he wants a four-year
deal you know what i was led to believe
is that if there was gonna be a fifth
year deal that it would have to be some
monstrous type of number in that fifth
year to protect himself from where the
market might be so i get all of that but
mike no that's the million dollar
question what what is it you know how
much guaranteed money do you need in the
contract to wipe away
okay yes like you're saying 69 million
in two years yeah for a guy who's never
been hurt you know knock on wood that
doesn't mean you're not gonna get hurt
going forward so it has to be that sweet
spot and dak prescott i do think because
of the size and the physicality of the
human being and the fact that he doesn't
hasn't been hurt to this point of his
career yeah he's probably a little bit
more confident confident maybe than
other quarterbacks that i could play
this kirk cousins type of franchise
dance and maybe capitalize i just think
it's a risky dance that's all i'm saying
and i don't know mike have you heard
guaranteed numbers that have been thrown
out there i mean i remember back early
in the spring we heard that he was
offered a little less maybe than carson
wentz was guaranteed money wise um but i
haven't heard anything on that ever
since but to me that's what it comes
down to do you feel the same way
well yeah and look the the standard
approach when it comes to franchise tag
players
and and this isn't a rule this is just
kind of the way that you get the deal
done the way you get the guy to trade in
his year-to-year opportunity you take
what he's gonna make over the first two
years and you fully guarantee that at a
minimum so at a minimum it's 69 million
fully guaranteed at signing for dak
prescott at a minimum
when you consider the possibility he
could walk away in 2022 what does that
turn into in guaranteed cash for 2022 if
any under this deal recognizing that if
the cowboys even if they only use the
transition tag in 2022 it's another 20
increase it's 45 million plus do the
math 31 4 37 6 8 45 plus you're getting
into huge numbers paid out over the
first three years and that may be
what his agents say okay we're not going
to ask you for the franchise tag in 2022
fully guaranteed we want this year
franchise tag next year franchise tag
third year transition tag add it all up
that's what we want guaranteed it's
signing it's a big number it's 100
million north of 100 million but right
this is the leverage he has and when you
consider two things one chris he's never
missed a game in his entire career
two
he's already bet on himself in one he's
already approached a year where he only
made two million for the full season he
rejected the offers that were made by
the team and he emerged on the other
side like andy dufresne with 31.4
million in his pocket so
now it's
hey i'll do it again yeah i did it last
year for two i'll gladly do it this year
for 31.4 and if you're making me do it
next year for 37.68 i'll do it again
and and see this is what we kind of been
waiting for ever since kirk cousins
because kirk cousins
when he was in washington not a
franchise quarterback and he played this
game year to year and he won big time
and from the moment he did it chris i'm
i was saying
a real franchise quarterback's gonna do
this one of these days and and the
numbers are gonna be a lot higher and
the stakes are gonna be a lot higher and
and you know everybody just assumes oh
deal gets done deal gets done because
deals always get done well they don't
always get done as kirk cousins proved
and uh
the point is
if i'm dak prescott it's gonna take a
lot
for me to give up 69 million over the
next two years plus this vague
jackpot that awaits after two more
football seasons i've already done 64
games i got 32 more
and after 32 more
i'm in an unprecedented situation i'm
getting 45 million of the transition tag
or 54 million under the franchise tag or
i'm walking away
yeah i i mean i get it i mean everything
you're saying is making sense i just
wonder what that number is what's that
number that the dallas cowboys and the
jones family has to throw out there i
mean right now right as far as just like
pure
guarantees at signing it and correct me
if i'm wrong aaron rodgers is still the
king of that like uh specific category
right mike i think it was 79.4 million
dollars like guaranteed at signing uh i
mean how much more does dak prescott
want than that and and again i mean to
me you know that this is where
i'm sure the jones family looks at this
and goes okay well doc prescott we love
you and everything like that but you
know we don't think you're quite aaron
rodgers yet at this point of your career
either so i i can see that doesn't
matter that doesn't matter i don't know
i know it doesn't matter
okay he'll take because anything less
than what he wants he'll say i'll just
take the 69 million over the next two
years okay i'll just take that that's it
i know i know but that's just yeah you
know that's a risk i wouldn't take i
don't know how you feel would you take
it if you were a quarterback i i
wouldn't and i wouldn't if i was back
here scott would i run the ball and i
play a little bit more of a physical
brand i would want to protect myself at
some point
here's where i would be if i was
prescott
i would say
i stepped in from day one
and i started for you from day one
because tony romo got injured and i
performed better than any of the
pre-tony romo quarterbacks that you guys
have had i stabilized the franchise at a
time when it could have gone off the
rails i took you to the playoffs twice i
won a playoff game against russell
wilson in the seattle seahawks the
window opened on a long-term deal after
my third season and you had an
opportunity to get me signed and you
lowballed me you didn't want to pay me
what i wanted and i was fully aware of
the bet that i made on myself for the
fourth year of my contract at two
million dollars you knew the bet i knew
the bet i won the bet now i want you to
pay me and if not i'll make another bet
at 31.4 i'll make another bet at 37.68
i'll force you to let me get to the open
market see this is the one thing the
people are going to resent dak prescott
remember this the cowboys exercised
their right to keep him off of the open
market and to keep him off of the two
first round picks pixes compensation
market too
they walked his path to see what anyone
else would pay him that's the great
unknown here we don't know what anyone
else would pay him the cowboys have
blocked via their rights under the cba
exactly what he would be able to do to
show everyone what he's worth what's his
market value
we don't know and we won't know right
until 2022. and you know what if i'm dak
prescott you keep pushing me and pushing
me and not giving me the offer that you
should have given me and keep trying to
throw your arm around me and give me a
little johnny walker blue and get me to
do a team-friendly deal no
i'm i'm running this now i've got rights
under the cba you put me in this
position i'm going to continue to do
this and then and then if you want to
try to sign me when i'm a free agent and
anybody else out there wants to sign me
and and you have to compete with them
then let's do it that way that that's
what i would do if i were dak prescott
it's easy for me to say it's easy for me
to say that because i'm not in that
position but that's what i would advise
him to do if he was my son my nephew my
cousin my friend my client i'll tell you
that
yeah well i mean listen i don't want to
be like you know misconstrued here i
mean i'm all for dak prescott getting
the money capitalizing as much as he
possibly can i certainly would like to
see him get it more than the jones
family right we know they got plenty of
money and yachts and everything else in
the world they're not going to be
hurting no matter what uh but but
i say these things and the only reason i
bring up these points and i'm not not
trying to argue with you or anything but
you know yeah me sitting here as a 39
year old i've been a guy that not
exactly in these shoes but have kind of
been in these shoes and it backfired on
me you know and i i got a big scar to
show it and a lot less money did not
show show you on the other side too so
that's where i just want to say be
careful you know we've seen with guys
like drew brees i mean he was this close
just a smidgen away from you know not
being able to throw the same way and not
being the same guy either when he was
with the san diego charger so that's all
i'm saying there just the risk factor it
is real to a person like me
you know what though mike i realize you
know when you haven't been hurt and i
can still remember the way i felt before
i had been actually really hurt in an
nfl football game i thought i was
indestructible and i thought i would
never get hurt so
i certainly can understand where dak
prescott is in that conversation in his
own brain
i remember the july 15 deadline applies
to all of the franchise tag players no
one who has been franchise tagged or
transition tagged only one guy was
transition tag kenyan drank at the
cardinals has signed a long-term deal
that's when it happens or it doesn't
happen and with so many guys this year
who have been tagged it's going to be an
active day when we get down to that july
15 window do you think mike anybody's
even going to try to do it mike do you
think like with the current
circumstances of the year
is are most teams going to just go you
know what we don't know what's gonna go
on for the next two years let's not sign
anybody to a long-term deal
but here's the problem chris
anybody who is franchise tagged this
year
is automatically entitled to that 20
raise next year regardless of what
happens with the salary cap so if you
can if you can find a way
to to smooth that out and get some
certainty on your roster for a guy that
you feel like you have to have you need
to take that into account because if the
cap does go down next year it doesn't
matter to the guys entering the second
year of the franchise tag unless there
would be some broader negotiation
between the nfl and the nflpa that would
only be ten percent increase or five
percent increase and they can negotiate
collectively anything they want but that
that would be my concern you're walking
into a bigger problem next year if it's
a guy you really want to keep on the
team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports